well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages as they arrive
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines
with the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace
and the economist at the irish news
alison morris lovely to see you both
hello to you
as over though we start with the front
pages telegraph
quoting the deputy chief medical officer
jonathan van tam
who said the south african variant is
not likely
to become the dominant strain here in
the uk
on the front page of the financial times
the government's moved to reassure
people
over the uk's vaccine program after
south africa stopped using the
astrazeneca jab
the guardian reports that scientists and
senior mps are calling for tighter
border controls
to protect the country from new variants
while the daily express says one
passenger
arriving at heathrow from south africa
was able to pass through the terminal in
just 10 minutes
in the yorkshire post over 70s have been
told to contact the nhs themselves
if they haven't yet been offered a
vaccine
that's also the front page of the eye as
the government says it's on track to
reach everyone
in the most at risk group by next monday
the daily mail says it's raised millions
of pounds to buy laptops for children
during lockdown and the metro leads on
storm darcy
warning that there's more winter weather
on the way
so mark wallace alison morrison here
welcome then to both of you
not surprising perhaps that the
government had to move to reassure
people about the
astrazeneca jab after the news from
south africa
yesterday um your take on it so far mark
do you think clear messaging then from
jonathan van tam and the health
secretary yes you know wham bam
jonathan van tam there he goes again
kind of getting
really to the nub of this issue which is
that obviously
variants are a concerning development
obviously there's something they're
keeping an eye on and i think we're
fortunate that
the uk is doing more genome sequencing
to try and track variants than just
about anybody else
um but as he said today very very
clearly
we've got to try to make sure that
people take the vaccine that will
protect them at least against the
current threat as swiftly as possible
and even the existing vaccine it seems
when it comes to this south african
variant offers some protection against
the very worst
effects of kobit 19 but the the really
important thing is that
if people are offered a vaccine that
they take it that they gain the
protection
against the existing threat which is
which is still circulating
right now so i think that that was
admirably to the point
yes and i suppose the whole point is
that with so many questions about the
handling of the pandemic
the terrible death rate that we've seen
in the uk alison
that governments are pinning absolutely
everything on this vaccine
and we all want it to work don't we so
we don't want to hear the
the bad news of elsewhere it is and i
suppose
you know headlines like we have seen
coming out of south africa can't spook
people a little
and it's important i think that
international travel is not just
controlled
but we look at you know quarantine and
people coming from those high-risk
countries to try
and stop the spread of it when we've
seen you know places
like new zealand like the isle of man
much closer to us and
other places which have used their sort
of island status much much more
effectively
that's the way to go but i mean vaccine
you know we know that this virus will
change and it will
adapt because it will try to survive as
we're trying to get rid of it
and that will happen and and that means
that the vaccine itself may need at some
stage a tweak which happens with other
vaccines that we
we all we have already taken regularly
that's very possible in the future
but i mean the the thing is is for not
to spit people to the point where they
think
that not getting the vaccine is a bad
idea or they try and hold off
for different vaccine because the only
way we ever have we
ever the only chance we have of getting
out of this cycle of lockdown release
lockdown release is getting the vaccine
rolled out as quickly as possible
yes and certainly some experts and i
think jonathan vantam talked about this
too
that the south africa africa study on
astrazeneca
was small unrepresentative with a young
cohort
the average age in their 30s not the
talk sort of age range that would
typically
be tested for serious cases or
hospitalizations which is more what
astrazeneca
has always said about its jab wasn't it
so in some respects
you know perhaps we should not be
heeding it quite as much as we have been
mark yes and actually if you see some
more detail in this telegraph from page
story it's really interesting that of
course
this is something that we have in common
with other questions about the
astrazeneca
vaccine the fact is that when you're
doing studies you do what you can
as early as possible and you take
various precautions so
you remember there were those queries
raised about
um i i think the german and french
health authorities didn't say that the
astrazeneca vaccine
wasn't good they didn't say there was
any elevated risk to it
but they said they wanted to wait for a
bit more data about older patients
because
the original study for for reasons of
very good reasons of caution
had a sample skewed younger in this
telegraph story
the telegraph reports that the who
expected within the next few days
apparently
to come out and say that it endorses the
astrozenica vaccine for use
in older patients and also to be very
positive about this
policy of opting to extend the gap
between doses to 12 weeks and
those things are really yet more good
news because it shows that the more we
learn about
these vaccines the more we learn about
their great benefits absolutely
um but let's move on shall we to uh the
other main part of the
of the news uh today which is this idea
is not mentioned of calling the nhs if
you still need a jab front page of the
eye
over 70s are told come on you know the
deadline is next monday
um call us if we've not got hold a hold
of you um but you're well ahead aren't
you in northern ireland alison
oh we are i mean originally when the the
vaccine first was rolled out they went
into the car homes and got got
the her homes and the car home staff
vaccinated quite quickly
and then started rolling it out through
the gp surgery so my parents were
originally told because they were in
their 70s they would probably not be
vaccinated until sometime around
february
i took them several weeks ago for their
first job and their due their second
quite soon and also they work on their
way through cars and all sorts of other
people
who might be in touch might be in
contact with vulnerable people so
we are well ahead i think that this
story is specifically in this call is
for people
who may be slightly off the grid may not
be registered with the gp
may not have been contacted already um
it's just for them to then be proactive
now and go
seeking to make sure that they get their
vaccine but i mean of
of all the things that we've seen i mean
i told i drove my parents up to get
their faxing i sat outside
the doctor's surgery when they went in
and it never stopped the cars just came
they went they came they went i mean
they're flying through them and i mean
at a rapid rate
which is so positive to see i actually
felt better as i drove away because you
could
say in the short time even that i was
there you know dozens of people were
vaccinated
yeah it's fantastic isn't it to see that
certainly um but there is concern isn't
there mark about black asian minority
ethnic communities
who are simply not taking up the jab as
much as they should
and they're sort of targeting you know
opening religious places of worship to
to vaccination for example
as a means of trying to counter that
indeed yes i'm not sure to what extent
we have kind of confirmed statistics
about the different
uptake levels between different ethnic
groups but that concern
is certainly there and you've seen some
very high profile communication done in
the last week or two
with politicians musicians and
celeb celebrities and other prominent
figures in different
communities all helping to get this
message out but the important thing is
that
people try to innovate in you know in in
different ways to make sure that the
policy is there to make it as
easy as possible to get this vaccine
essentially to say to people you know
what
don't make an excuse not to get it make
an excuse to make sure you go and get it
yes and i think the message to social
media companies to remove
you know um problem uh messaging as well
which might start putting some people
off certainly
um what about the money then uh it to
the times
johnson banks a short boost to universal
credit payments this is one of those
issues we wait for as we
await the budget uh here obviously
alison what's this story about in the
times
well yeah they're saying that um boris
johnson is back in this six months
shortly
so people were given a 20 boost to their
universal credit
at the start of lockdown to try and get
them through what are exceedingly hard
times especially for those people who
are on the lowest income
more so at this time of year when we
know that heating bills and electricity
bills and all sorts of other things
go up um there was a plan hopefully to
roll it out for over a year but then i
said the government is looking to roll
it out for six months because of the
cost of that
that's actually a devolved issue here so
in northern ireland it will be the storm
and assembly which will decide
what has happened to the universal
credit boost in relation to that
but the fact is you can say you'll give
people the boost but then you've got to
find the money from the budget
to do it as well so i know that there'd
be debate here
as well going forward and just how long
that base can continue for
yes indeed and and the question is for
for all governments of the uk mark there
comes a reckoning at some point are we
nearing the point financially where the
reckoning happens or is there a belief
that
this variant is so bad actually the
restrictions will last for longer than
even the likes of uh mark harper or
sergey and brady would like to see
well that's a major part of the
calculation here of course the fact is
that
last summer things looked an awful lot
different to how they looked by mid to
late autumn
and we don't yet know exactly how the
variants are going to interact
with the vaccines it certainly seems
we've got what's the great news of the
fast vaccine
rollouts we're just talking about but
without that knowledge it's very hard i
think for them to plan
exactly when they have to start trying
to rebalance the books i'm gonna say i
wouldn't be too surprised
amid all this speculation if the budget
was a little bit more generous on this
front than is currently being briefed
but
nobody yet knows okay sounded like you
did for a moment
maybe not uh plenty more from you too
coming up uh shortly including
elon musk's tesla has bought 1.5 billion
dollars worth of bitcoin making it climb
more than 10
to a record 44 000 but why discussing
that just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the chief
executive of conservative home
mark wallace and the columnist at the
irish news alice morris welcome back to
both of you
um alison let's go to the financial time
shall we eye-watering sums of money
spent by
the very rich man that is elon musk on
the cryptocurrency
bitcoin tell us more well yeah they're
saying that elon musk has purchased 1.5
billion
dollars worth of bitcoin which is
obviously sent
the um currency rates of cryptocurrency
has increased the value of them
across the board given that he's shown
such an interest he's saying
that he will allow people to use bitcoin
to buy his electric cars
up until now it's always been a mystery
as to what you can actually spend
bitcoin on we've you know all heard
these stories of you know pizza delivery
drivers becoming billionaires but never
actually worked out
what it can be spent on but there's a
great line in this story because we know
about
um elon musk's and fascination with
space he's a sort of you know bond
body type character who's you know all
sorts of
all sorts of uh strange technologies but
he's it says that you know his his plans
are to
explore mars and who knows whether the
martians will accept cryptocurrency
um if they don't it has 1.5 billion
pounds worth it's sitting in a
room somewhere i don't know what he's
going to do with it yeah well three
landings on mars this year
you know it's it's the new frontier as
they say i'm very excited about them or
my children
are anyway um but let's move on to
pensions not quite the same
really as visits to mars um but the
burden the telegraph
tells us uh is getting quite expensive
as well
yes i think frankly we could probably do
with some of elon musk's um
one and a half billion dollars and
growing in bitcoin to fill
this growing black hole the large huge
liabilities that are booming
and facing uh uk taxpayers firstly from
the pensions lock but also from you know
gold-plated final salary public sector
pensions those really big commitments
a lot of which on the public sector
large chunks of which
simply aren't funded yet we have to pay
for them in future but we're on the hook
to finance them do they still exist mark
yes um if you if you look at the ons um
figures comparing pension and
commitments the problem is of course
that
if you had somebody who joined one of
these schemes even
20 30 years ago they could well still be
working in and yet to qualify for
uh to actually draw down the pension but
a lot of them
you know the taxpayer the exchequer has
not been setting enough money aside to
eventually pay for these they've done it
on the never never
okay interesting uh plenty more from you
at half past eleven for the moment thank
you both very much indeed alison morris
and uh mark mullis thank you both very
much indeed
so alice and mark are here uh let's go
straight to the daily telegraph alison
shall we
uh which is news of vaccines and
variants once again
um and this is reassurance that the
south african variant
is not likely to become the dominant
variant in this country that was from
jonathan van tam today
no when they're they're only so far have
only managed detect around 147 cases
of the south african variant which is
good news um and and i do think you know
we do know that there will be various
variants as time goes on
but this is really the time that we sort
of squandered
during the the first lockdown when we've
managed to get cases so
low but yet didn't do anything about
international travel so
you can you know we need to stop the
variant from spreading but we also i
think need to
to make sure there's restrictions on
travel as well they also there's a
really good line in this story which is
the world health organization
is about to endorse the astrozonica
vaccine
for all um adult age groups which is for
which is a really positive development
so
anyone who is unsure about taking this
vaccine and is maybe thinking
because of the news coming out of south
africa they should maybe wait on a
different vaccine
i think that that should reassure them
that if they're offered it and if you're
offered it
to take it because it's the only way to
break this lockdown cycle that we're in
yes and there was a suggestion today
that this south african study
mark was small it was unrepresentative
it involved
young people average age early 30s and
therefore there was no testing
of whether the vaccine the estrogenic
vaccine would protect against
serious illness and hospitalizations and
mortality
which is you know the really important
bit that everybody's trying to achieve
do you feel reassured do you think after
after the news conference
this afternoon yes yeah i think
it was clear about what they do and
crucially about what they don't know and
it's fair to say there are limitations
to this study as you say it was small it
tended towards a
younger age group but it may have
flagged up a
you know a genuine issue with regard to
the south africa
variant and and how it interacts with
some vaccines but
the crucial thing about the press
conference as jonathan vantam said
is the big issue the big pressing issue
we have is with
variants of this virus that this vaccine
is effective against and people
therefore need to take the vaccine they
need to protect themselves
and to protect others and if further
down the line
we have to have updates and boosters of
one vaccine or another based on
different variants then that is abridged
across when we come to it but
at this stage this vaccine is the right
thing to do it
will help to save lives and to reduce
damage and therefore people i think
we're rightly being encouraged to
continue taking it
and the other big message from the
government today front page of the eye
and elsewhere call the nhs if you still
need a jab this is the message to the
over 70s
the deadline obviously to try and get
all over 70s
vaccinated is early next week northern
ireland though alison
um is already ahead of that curve is it
not
we are and there was a a helpline
released last week that encouraged
people over 65
to start contacting and try and book in
to get their their first job
and as i said my parents are in their
70s they weren't you to have their first
vaccination till near the end of this
month they've already in january
had their first job on our due to their
second quite shortly
um we also in northern ireland they
managed to get through the car homes
very quickly
and the car home staff which was the
really big issue as we know
outbreaks and car homes were what were
responsible for a large proportion of
deaths so
we're working ahead we are ahead without
we have a much smaller population here
as well
but it's good because if we look at you
know our close neighbors in the south of
ireland they are a lot further behind
than we are you know people in the rear
east
in the south are still waiting on their
first vaccination so it's really good
news in terms of
the vaccination front and heart were
managing to get through it and when i
took my parents
the health clinic that they go to it was
you know a constant stream of people
dozens of people were vaccinated while i
was sitting outside in my car the coming
and going
was really positive and i think that
that's the only thing it's given any of
us hope that we may have some sort of
normality come
this summer yes and indeed boris johnson
will announce
uh the rollout for england at least on
february the 22nd
talk of schools possibly going back
march the 8th
but not such great news from jonathan
van tan mark on the prospect of a summer
holiday effectively saying
the more complicated your holiday is if
it crosses borders then there's more to
unravel when we simply don't know and
that's that's the stage we're at isn't
it the vaccine is one thing
the variants are another and the rest of
the world is um
you know we wait and see absolutely
in in the end in the grand scheme of
things we live in
an interconnected world and this race to
vaccination is one that we all need each
other every other country to win
and as well as us it's really important
really great that
we're doing so well and things are going
so quickly on vaccination you know
thanks to everyone from the medical
staff
uh jabbing people right the way up to
nadine zahari
who did that essential work in getting
the vaccine supply on track
but it's going to be a very long time
before we know exactly how the rest of
the world is going to open up and
who frankly is going to be willing to um
[Music]
open their borders and pursue those
different travel plans um this is yet to
be seen
yes and who would welcome those from the
uk um
with the uk variant uh which many people
are as spooked as the south african
variant of aren't they that's the
that's the difficulty it takes us though
to the guardian um alison
uh johnson urged to tighten borders
suggestions that those even not on the
red list need to get tested twice what
are the details of this then
yeah well already there is a requirement
for people to have been tested but
they're nice and that anyone who travels
through the airports at all should then
again be tested two days after arriving
regardless of where they're coming from
and i think you know all of this is is
you know it should be put in place and
it should be especially put in place
before
travel opens up and increases again we
had an
issue last week in the northern assembly
where there was discussions about
whether or not they would open hotels
which are currently closed beside the
airport
for people to quarantine in for three
weeks we don't really have any
international flights coming in and out
of
belfast or any of the airports at the
moment the issue i suppose is people
could fly from those countries
to london and then cook a quick you know
one hour by stepping stone
over to northern ireland so all of that
needs to be looked at in terms of
international travel
um in both directions and you know and i
think that
there probably will come a time when
you'll be asked to show
that you've been vaccinated before you
travel further on down the line but
right now i think you know a negative
test
is the very minimum requirement that we
should be expecting if any of us need to
travel anywhere
the other big issue um as we mentioned
is education uh daily stars had a bit of
fun with this
as our kids face the biggest ever
schools crisis
we have one question regarding our
missing in action education secretary
gavin williamson now we are told to
expect a news conference from him
when the moment arises about uh the plan
for schools eventually
um but you know answer answer the
where's
willy question mark but also are you
getting any indications
about the how the why and the where of
the lifting of restrictions
in the weeks and months ahead
well the answer to both of those
questions is i don't know
and ultimately when you we do a monthly
survey
of conservative party members on
conservative home and one of the
questions we ask is we ask them to rate
the performance of different cabinet
ministers and
gavin williamson i'm sorry to say is
by far and away the lowest scoring
cabinet minister at the moment so it's
not just the star who's giving him black
about that
do you also ask people to rate whether
they want restrictions to continue in
the face of this
variant or not we we have we always ask
we ask different questions uh on kind of
topical issues each month that wasn't in
the latest survey but you know it might
be the next one
okay should i urge him to do it and
we'll all find out
um but alison do you get do you get a
sense that uh people are in this for the
long haul
which it might be or do you get a sense
i mean it's difficult isn't it
with with the weather being indoors a
lot
the homeschooling i mean everyone's very
tired but do you get a sense that people
can stick with
this do you think i think as long as we
know that there's hope
you know people are able to accept that
the lockdown will continue for
a short time more but they need to know
there's hope at the end of that and i
think that that's where
sorry the vaccine comes into play
mark just quickly yeah the the fact the
fact is that this is having a really
serious effect
people know the lockdown and is white
there they know why it's needed
but that doesn't change the fact that a
lot of us can can see that it
obviously isn't ideal particularly for
our children okay both of you let you
have a good cough
alison um hopefully not too bad a cough
uh we'll see you in just a moment plenty
more still to come including uh bitcoin
takes a step
closer to the mainstream as the electric
car company tesla
buys 1.5 billion of the currency
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now chief
executive
get it out conservative home mark
wallace and the columnist at the irish
news
alison morris welcome to both of you um
so let's go to the
ft mark shall we uh they're leading on
johnson putting faith in
the astrazeneca vaccine but the story
you picked out just below that
it's about tesla and bitcoin uh tell us
more
well this is a symptom of two things and
the first is that tesla due to its
uh massive soaring share price is
sitting on a huge heap of money
and the second thing is that elon musk
is someone who thinks outside the box
and does
relatively unconventional things and
they've piled a huge amount of that
money one half billion dollars
into bitcoin that is his new big bet
which is helping to drive that
market further and that
the whole point is that there's he's got
an eye on space what's the quote that
you like in this story um
allison from the ft oh yeah and there's
a mention in this of of the fact that
obviously
a long muscus space program is looking
at exploring mars and and one expert
said
maybe the martians would be able to
accept cryptocurrency because
up until now i think that anyone who has
bought huge amounts of cryptocurrency
have
found it quite difficult to find
something to use it on
and anyone who has bought any of that
i'm not really sure i
still understand how it works um the
share price obviously that has been
through the roof because
elon musk has bought 1.5 billion dollars
with uh with bitcoin so um i think it is
little boys in their toys sometimes they
think that they
must we're all fascinated by him he
lives a sort of life of a bone body you
know with with all the
these he has his own rockets his own
space program his own electric cars
and now he almost owns all of bitcoin as
well yes brilliant
um let's move on to uh another cost
though
uh not least the kovid cost but this is
moving to the pension
burden uh tell us more about this in the
telegraph then mark
so this is you know one of one of the
aspects of kind of financial hangover
that all of us are going to have to
start getting into
aside from everything that's been spent
because of lockdown and
and the impact of covert and the
pandemic this is the pension
bill which is growing and growing and
it's partially
the effect of the pension lock on
the the state pension but it's also the
remarkable
high cost a lot of it troublingly
unfunded effectively sitting on a black
hole
of quite a lot of public sector pension
funds which we're going to have to be
paid for out of future taxes well that's
interesting isn't it
and um one might expect that in other
times they might think about
renegotiating these pensions but
obviously the support now is for
public sector workers who brought
everybody through this pandemic alison
yeah and you imagine any of them could
expect that their pension
should be ring fenced and should be
there for them when they finish their
service given the fact
that they have managed to sail through
this terrible time i think that when we
hear
stories of problems in relation to
pension and how this pension pot is
going to be
filled and where people are going to be
paid what they've worked all their lives
and deserve
suppose it makes us all worry about
what's going to happen to pensions not
just in the the public but the private
sector too i always have
you know notions of me on my summer
frames staggering around belfast trying
to cover you know parades in the summer
or something so i really hope
you know that the pensions aren't in as
dire situation as they are but we've had
quite
a lot of public spend and we know that
the covert spending has been huge and
all of this will have to be
paid back by future generations
they're your decades and decades and
decades away from that image which
you know obviously we hope never happens
uh alison and mark lovely to see both
thank you